JON ORWANT: Well, welcome,
everyone, to yet another
Authors at Google Talk.
My name is Jon Orwant.
I'm with Google Research.
And I have the pleasure and the
honor today of introducing
someone who, in my opinion, is
one of the foremost writers of
our generation.
I say foremost writer and not
foremost science fiction
writer or foremost hard science
fiction writer in part
because of a class I took about
15 or 20 years ago from
AI pioneer Marvin Minsky.
The discussion kind of strayed
to modern literature, and he
talked about what it was
that he liked to read.
And he said that when it came
to fiction, he only read
science fiction.
He never read anything else.
That was the only genre
that he read.
And people would occasionally
call him on this and say,
don't you feel like that
makes you narrow, only
reading this one genre?
And his reply I remember to this
day, which was, no, I'm
not the one being narrow.
You're the one being narrow.
Because of all what you call
regular literature, that's
just about the seven
deadly sins.
Science fiction is about
everything else.
And I can't think of another
living writer who better
encompasses that notion of
science fiction being about
everything else than our guest
today, who has an unparalleled
ability to envision the
intersection of culture and
environment in a way that paints
a world in very high
resolution.
Now, that said, his latest book,
"Shaman," is not really
science fiction.
In fact, it's about the
seven deadly sins.
It's a coming of age story
of a young man.
And if I just stopped my
description there, I think
most science fiction aficionados
wouldn't want to
read the book.
But then, you hear it's by a
science fiction author, and
you think, OK, well, maybe it's
a coming of age story of
someone on a distant
planet that's very
different from our planet.
That would kind of be in
our author's style.
Or maybe it's 300 years in the
future, like his latest book,
the book before this one,
"2312." Or maybe it's about a
coming of age story
of a robot.
It's not any of those things.
I think to some extent, it's
easy to write the typical
science fiction novel, because
if you're talking about a
distant planet or someplace
that's in the future, you can
make stuff up, right?
No one's going to be able
to call you on it.
Instead, this book is about our
planet in the past, and
it's not a Civil War romance.
The past is 32,000 years ago
in the upper Paleolithic.
It's the story of a Cro-Magnon,
and this is at a
time when the Cro-Magnons were
living with Neanderthals.
And the author really had to
do a whole lot of research,
and I'm looking forward to
learning about the research
that he did to get this book,
because this book is going to
be a hit, and it's going to be
pored over by archaeologists,
by sociologists, by
anthropologists, by
historians, by linguists, to
figure out if he really got
everything right.
Because I guarantee you after
you read this book, when you
think about Cro-Magnons, the
images that are going to pop
into your head are going
to be the images
that are painted here.
So our guest today has won a
Hugo Award, he's won a Nebula
award, he's won the John
Campbell Memorial Award, he's
won the Locus Award, he's won
the World Fantasy Award.
Some of those awards
more than once.
So please join me in giving
a very warm welcome to Kim
Stanley Robinson.
[APPLAUSE]
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON:
Thank you.
I'm going to use this.
So thank you very much, Jon,
for that kind introduction.
And I will say that this book,
Shaman, is one that I consider
to be science fiction, because
without the science of
archaeology, we wouldn't know
what I'm writing about here.
So I'm going to read two brief
passages, and these are
specifically chosen
for Google.
This is my fifth time at Google,
and the first time
that I've come to read
you all a book.
Before that, it's been
different kinds of
conferences.
And so this, actually, for me,
is kind of fun to finally get
to read to this crowd.
And these are the two Google
Earth passages from this book.
The first one should only last
about five minutes, and the
second one also about
five minutes.
And then I want to hear
questions, and I'll talk more
about the process of
doing this book.
So OK, here's the
first passage.
And this is, you have to
imagine, essentially, kind of
a Burning Man Festival
30,000 years ago.
Central Europe.
Summer day.
In fact, the 8/8 Festival, which
would be August 8th.
On the morning of the last day,
he and Elga and Lucky
went to the broad, sandy bank
of the meadow's river, where
there was a group of men in the
sun busy at work on their
bird's eye views.
As always, it was mostly an old
man's game, and the more
they had wandered in their
lives, the better they were at
it, and the more interested.
It was a traveler's game.
Now, a lot of old men and a
few old women-- maybe two
score in all-- were strolling
about watching those who were
actively making views.
The makers crouched and tiptoed
about on the edges of
their patches, stretching far
out to smooth and shape the
sand to what they thought some
part of the world would look
like from the sky if shrunk to
the size of their patch.
The areas they portrayed were
sometimes big, extending from
the festival grounds and the
caribou steppe to the
mountains to the south and the
great salt sea to the west.
Others portrayed
smaller areas.
There were distinct styles,
which Loon thought were
something like the way wall
paintings were either three
liners or fully detailed.
Some views were made simply of
wet sand molded into the
shapes of the land by hand and
stick, so that one saw them
stripped flesh of the
land, so to speak.
Others used moss for meadows,
twigs for trees, pebbles
shoved into the sand to look
like the gleam of water seen
from on high, even some little
toy animals in shelters and
people taken from kids'
camp games.
Someone had even packed down
snow to represent the ice caps
on the central highlands.
And in one old woman's view,
even the great ice wall of the
north, here ankle high.
It was funny to see these little
worlds as if one were
an eagle at the highest point
of its gyre, and some of the
decorative views were
quite beautiful.
But what the makers mostly
discussed was how
accurate they were.
Long sticks were used to
point out features.
Traveling stories were related
with lots of argument about
what a day's walk meant in terms
of a stretch of land.
This last argument was
impossible to resolve, both in
principle and in relation to the
shrinking they had done to
reduce a big part of the earth
to three strides on a side.
But it obviously gave many of
them immense pleasure to
discuss it at length with sand
hills and canyons to point to.
"I was in this valley you
mark as shallow, but
it's deeper than that.
I passed through its 12 month,
and the sun never came out
over the southern ridge,
so you need to have it
deeper." "Maybe so.
Here, I'll scoop it down
a bit." And so on.
At the end of the session, they
would all declare their
favorites, and a Best of Day
would be declared, and the
winner given a bucket of mash
and a chance to brag for a
fist or two.
And then they would all stand
around the edges of the view,
observers and maker both, and
leap out onto the little
worlds and trample them to a
chaos of torn sand worse than
the mud at a caribou ford.
Gods destroying worlds, and
while it lasted, it was the
best dance of all.
They shouted and laughed as
they leaped and kicked.
It felt glorious.
So we can discuss this later,
but I want to point out to you
that the Ohlone Native
Americans--
the Ohlone that lived in
this very Bay Area--
did this very thing for European
visitors who first
came to the Bay Area.
So although it's speculation on
my part, I'm sure that this
actually was happening
back in that time.
Now, here, again, the last piece
that I'll read for you
today is about the
same like that.
It's another--
well, it's a traveler's tale.
You have to imagine a
night by the fire.
Just an ordinary night
by the fire, but a
traveler has come by.
I am a traveller, as you know.
I walk the surface of Mother
Earth, and so do my fellow
travelers, each of us
on his own path.
And some of us repeat our paths
as long as we can find
them, and nothing makes us
take a different way.
I'm one of those myself, having
a wife with my brother,
and he goes out when I'm at
home, and he doesn't like it
when I'm overly late, although
both of us have been delayed
once or twice through
the years.
What this means for me is I go
out east to the gate between
worlds, and then turn north
and walk for a fortnight,
right up to the edge of the
great ice cap, and come back
just under that great white
wall, or sometimes up on the
ice itself, if the summer melt
has made the land next to the
ice impassable.
West I return, and south across
the steppes to home,
using paths of my own
that no one knows--
the best ways of all.
That's the way it is for me,
but in my travels, I meet
other men out walking in the
world, and some of them have
neither circuit nor home, but
wander always a new way.
These men are curious people,
odd in their ways and speech,
but interesting for
that, and we talk.
Always when travelers get
together over a fire, we talk.
You can see that right
now, I know.
And travelers together
talk about traveling.
Where have you been?
What have you seen?
What are the people like?
What's out there on this
world we live on?
These are the questions we ask
and the stories we tell, and
some travelers travel to find
the answers and tell new
stories to those they meet.
One such I met this summer at
the farthest east of all the
places I go.
This man looked like the
Northers, and I could barely
understand him, but I could.
And it got easier as we talked,
because he had only
one thing to talk about, which
was this world we live on--
its shape and size.
All travelers agree, for we've
seen it ourselves.
There is ice to the north
wherever you go, and to the
West is the great salt sea.
And to the south, again, the
salt sea, although warmer and
more calm--
more in and out, and dotted
with islands.
We all agree on this, we
travelers, as between us,
we've seen it all, and some
travelers claim to have seen
it all themselves alone.
Good.
Maybe they are even
telling the truth.
I can't say.
But here's the thing.
What about east?
This northern man was
like a lot of us.
He had that question.
And more than that, he wanted
to know the answer,
and no one had it.
So he took off walking
east, he said.
He walked for days, he
walked for months,
he walked for years.
He walked east from the time
this question had come to him
in his youth, and kept on
walking until he was a man in
the middle of life.
17 years, he said,
he walked east.
I asked him what he had seen
on this life walk.
He told me of steppes that
went on forever.
There were mountains like those
to the west of here, and
some lakes bigger than
any I've seen.
Little salt seas, even.
Their water was salt, he said.
But mostly, it was steppes.
You know what that's like.
The walking is good if it isn't
too wet, and there are
always animals to eat.
So there really was no
impediment to him.
Yet there he sat, across a fire
from me, as far to the
east as I had ever been.
But it was only the gate of
worlds, a nice, broad pass
between low mountains
to north and south.
It had taken him 12 years to
walk back to where we were.
This he told me.
Finally, I had to ask him.
Why did you come back?
Having gone so far,
why turn around?
Why not keep going for the
rest of your life?
He stared into the fire for a
long, long time before he met
my eye and answered me.
"When I was as far east as I
got," he said, "I came to a
hill and went up it to look.
I was feeling poorly, and my
feet hurt, and no person I had
met for several years spoke
any word I understood.
All my dealings were
done by sign.
You can do that and still get
by, but after a while, you
want a word with the people you
see." I Pippi could only
agree to that.
And so, he said, he stood on
that hill, and all to the east
was just the same.
There was no sign at all
it would ever change.
"I realized," he said, "that
this world is just too big.
You can't have it all, no matter
how much you want it.
It's bigger than any man
can walk in one life.
Possibly it just keeps
going on forever.
Possibly our Mother Earth is
round," he said then, "like a
pregnant woman or the moon, and
if you walk long enough,
you would come around to where
you started, assuming the
great salt sea did
not stop you.
But really, there is no
way to know for sure.
And so I turned back," he said,
"because the world is
too big, and most of all, I
wanted to talk to somebody
again before I died."
Having said that, having told
his tale, we stood and hugged,
and he cried so hard I thought
he would choke.
I had to hold him up.
Whether he had succeeded or
failed in his life walk, he
did not know, and
I didn't either.
After that, he calmed down,
and we looked at the fire
until long in the night, telling
other stories we knew.
And before bed, I asked him,
"So what's for you now?
What will you do, now
that you're back?"
"Well," he said, "to tell the
truth, I'm thinking I may take
off east
again." Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Google Earth, 30,000 BC,
or before present.
And those are only the most
momentarily relevant of the
speculative passages in this
book as to trying to think out
how the people of that time knew
their worlds, given the
limited ability that they had
to comprehend what they were
up to, and the limited ability
they had to pass on what they
learned, because there
was no writing.
This was the crucial thing.
This is human beings, the same
DNA as us, very accomplished.
The only DNA differences that
a lot of us have lactose
tolerance, and none
of them did.
Otherwise, they're us.
But they didn't have writing,
and writing is very much of a
consciousness changing
technology.
Very much so.
Maybe even more than the
internet, which is another
possibly major consciousness
changing activity.
We don't know yet.
So I had to get into the world
of the pre-literate, the oral
mind, where there must
be, I don't know, 30
poems in the book.
But they're not poetry in the
modern sense, but rather just
information.
There's also probably 100
proverbs in the book--
another way that people could
hold on to what had been
learned and pass it along.
It was an ear culture, and
it was about remembering.
And it's about the cave
paintings, especially the
Chauvet cave.
Those of you who have had the
joy of seeing Werner Herzog's
most recent film, "The Cave of
Forgotten Dreams," you have
already seen the visual
illustration of this book of
mine, because I wrote
about the people who
painted that cave.
And that's why it's 32,000 years
ago, because that's when
that cave was painted.
And I think that's all I want to
tell you right here at the
start, before I get some
questions to direct me into
talking about other
parts of it.
And I can go on without them,
but I would love to have
questions to direct me
to areas of interest.
AUDIENCE: So you found the
setting from the caves.
How did you settle on--
you can tell this is a question
from an author wannabe--
on the arc?
What was going to happen?
Did you sort of just start off
and let it happen, decide when
it was done, or did you know
where you were going?
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON:
Well, that's a good
question for everybody.
The other stimulus for me in the
writing of this book was
the discovery of the Iceman
between Austria and Italy in
1991, who had been frozen
in the glacier
with all of his gear.
And his gear was remarkably
similar to the backpacking
gear that I take when I go up in
the Sierras, and it proved
that they were a high
tech culture.
His gear was magnificent, and
came from about 60 different
sources in a wide region.
It took a full culture to make
the gear that this guy had.
And so I'd thought, well,
let's look into the
archaeology and find out a
storyline that would not be
just a wanderer like the Iceman
or like the traveler
that tells his tale, but would
allow me to get to the heart
of their culture.
And the things I was interested
in was how did
science begin in its
true beginnings,
and how did art begin?
And it turns out that at that
time, really, these were not
identical efforts.
They never have been.
But the herb women, who were
essentially doing medicine,
they were really the
first scientists.
Trial and error, take something,
see what effect it
has on you.
It was very rough and ready,
because they didn't have much
in the way of ability to
differentiate the effects from
the causes.
But nevertheless, that was the
first science, really.
And then the first art seems
to be associated with these
caves and with the shamanistic
religion.
That's one of two competing
theories as to what those cave
paintings are about, and they
sort of supersede the first
guess that it was
hunting magic.
The hunting magic theory
has gone away.
And what it's been replaced by
is that it was a shamanistic
religion, or it was
teenagers--
probably teenage boys-- screwing
around and doing
graffiti on a dare, scaring
themselves and doing
pornography and graffiti.
And the paintings--
there's a lot of incompetence
and beginner cave art that
doesn't get reproduced in the
art books and the Herzog film.
So I think both theories are
possibly true, and are not in
competition with each other.
But the absolute expertise of
the big, good paintings that
you see, and the fact that in
Lascaux, they're the ceilings--
and as Gary Schneider put it,
there needed to be an arts
administration in the
Paleolithic to get the
scaffolding together to get the
artists that high on the
ceiling suggests that we're
really in something quite
professional here.
So by telling the story of a
shaman, I could tell the story
of the whole culture.
And if he was associated with
an herb woman, and they did
medicine together, so that you
had the mind-body effect, and
that you could talk
about both.
And since all these
relationships were being
passed along master to
apprentice, then if I had an
apprentice, then I would have
essentially a portrait of the
artist as a young man.
I would have the bildungsroman,
a classic form,
a young man.
And maybe he's good at some
parts of it, but not good at
other parts of it so that maybe
he likes the painting,
but has a poor memory,
especially for poetry, which I
myself have a terrible
memory for poetry.
I could relate to that.
So slowly but surely, by the
desire to show the whole
culture, a character
begins to develop.
Some relationships
begin to develop.
And then you do need a plot.
I mean, I think novels
are about daily life.
They're about how did people
live back then?
But if it only was that, it
would become anthropology.
And you need to a plot where
essentially, daily life gets
broken, and something
else happens.
Well, I didn't want to impose
anything particularly modern.
I didn't want to say--
although this is not
a bad idea--
have a murder mystery that
the shaman had to solve.
I mean, this would be the
typical imposition.
We have medieval monk
detectives, we have Roman
detectives, I could have had
a Paleolithic detective.
I'm glad I didn't go that way.
But if you have different kinds
of culture, many of the
oldest stories that we have
out of the prehistoric
literature have to do with
intratribal conflicts,
including people kidnapped
and stolen from
one tribe by another.
And at that point,
you've got an
extremely intense situation.
More intense, even, than the
murder mystery, which is kind
of NCI forensic, and I can't
tell you how sick
I am of that scenario.
So that was how I went about
the building of it.
It sounds fairly Tinker
Toy or Erector Set.
It sounds fairly rational,
and it is.
But at a certain point, what
one would hope is that it
begins to take over, and it
begins to come to life.
And it's essentially kind
of Calvin and Hobbes.
At some point, Hobbes had better
wake up and start doing
his part of things.
And at that point, you've got
a book on your hands.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned the
Ohlone as a culture that
inspired the book.
What other cultures did you look
at for inspiration on how
people would relate to each
other and what their beliefs
may be and stuff like that?
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON: Well, I
looked at almost all of what
we used to call Stone Age
cultures that were still
functioning when we got there,
but especially the Australian
Aborigines, the Inuit, and the
Athapaskans, because I was in
an ice scenario, and I wanted
to go north into the polar
regions and see how people
lived there.
So the Athapaskans of Alaska
were really important, partly
because they had such a
good anthropologist
visit them early on.
And so the information
was really rich.
Then also, everybody has to look
at the Bush people or the
Kung, because they were such
a high functioning and so
suggestive.
They were so well studied,
and still out there.
And those were the main.
And then all North
American tribes--
like, I would just get
anthologies of Native American
poetry and proverbs.
But I would say, really, the
Athapaskans, the Inuit, and
the Aborigines were probably
the three main.
And so you understand that I'm
doing all this by analogy
backwards, and I'm saying that
these are cultures that were
basically studied in the 19th
century, and it isn't clear
that they weren't disturbed by
modernity before they were
studied, or that the
anthropologists got things wrong.
What I'm assuming is that if
it looks like people were
doing it 10,000 years ago, that
they were doing it 30,000
years ago-- that there was
that kind of continuity.
So this is something that no
self respecting archaeologists
can make these kind of
speculative leaps.
And in fact, it's really against
the rules now in the
hardcore archaeology, to the
point where they don't like
this shaman interpretation
of the cave paintings.
They're saying, this
is such a guess.
We can't possibly know.
Let's just concentrate
on what we can know.
And of course, that really
cuts a lot of stuff out.
But when you're doing a
novel, you don't have
to worry about that.
AUDIENCE: So how did you decide,
in my world, 30,000
years ago, they were
not doing that yet?
How did you decide?
Was it driven by the story, or
driven by your belief in
what's likely to
have happened?
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON: It was
driven first by what did I
think was happening, and guided
by archaeologists.
They don't have bow and
arrows in this book.
I mean, that's part of what the
archaeologists say, that
bow and arrows are relatively
recent-- maybe
6,000 or 7,000 years.
Happily, as Jon pointed out,
the Neanderthal were there
32,000 years ago.
That's pretty solid.
And they were domesticating
wolves into dogs around that
time, which we used to say was
15,000 years ago, and now the
genetic evidence pushed
it back to more
like 40,000, or 30,000.
It was, in other words,
right in my time.
And so they had spear throwers,
but not bow and arrow.
And what I was saying is they
for sure had snowshoes,
although everything that they
made out of leather or straw
or even wood has rotted
away in 30,000 years.
We got nothing but stone, bone,
ivory, tooth, and shell,
and the cave paintings.
So our evidence for 30,000
years ago is so slight.
In other words, I tried to be
only as conservative as would
keep an archaeologist from
being completely
tossed out of the book.
But other than that, saying,
like, did suspect that the
Earth was round?
Did they know about the
Mediterranean, the Atlantic,
and the ice cap?
How geographically centered
where they were--
nobody can say no to me, but
it's a matter of speculation,
because we have no evidence
whatsoever.
We do know that there are
cultures that have some
objects they come from over
1,000 miles away.
But whether they got traded
five miles at a time, or
whether there were people
doing it the whole
way, nobody can say.
It's a nice open slate
in that regard.
AUDIENCE: When doing your
research, what were some
things that were kind of
concrete that surprised you
that you learned?
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON: Well, we
see evidence that although
they were preliterate, they were
beginning to keep records
and mark things.
So that did surprise me.
A journalist who got interested
named Marshack sort
of made himself into an
archaeologist just by writing
was supposed to be a popular
science book, but he found all
the evidence in the literature
and in the record that people
were marking bones, and every
28 or 29 days, there was an
extra loop.
So it looked like they were
mark in the months.
And the months, of course,
are marked by the moon.
So there's no need to know
where you are in a month,
because the moon is telling you
in the sky every night.
It's like a giant clock.
But the discrepancy between the
solar year and the lunar
year is irreconcilable by
direct observation.
You can get pretty good,
but not very good.
And so it looks like people
were trying to figure out,
here we got these
lunar months.
So convenient.
Big clock in the sky.
But then the sun going
to the solstices--
the equinox and the solstices
again-- are offset.
Well, what's with that?
And it looks like people at
least 40,000 years ago were
trying to keep track so that
they might be able to
reconcile it.
I thought that was beautiful.
It's kind of a Stonehenge
thing.
It's kind of a computer thing.
And the evidence is there
to make that case.
Also, the Iceman had tattoos.
That cracked me up.
JON ORWANT: So I had the good
fortune to have an advance
copy of your book.
And in that book, there
was no preface.
There was no forward.
I don't know if that's the
case in the actual book
[INAUDIBLE].
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON: No,
no, none of that.
Terrible idea.
JON ORWANT: And so, I mean,
one of the things that I
enjoyed as a result of that kind
of lack of context, just
being kind of thrust into the
story, is I was, in a sense,
reading two stories, right?
There was the arc of the story
that you told, but there was
also this meta mystery to me of
trying to figure out when
this was taking place and where
this was taking place.
And there was a particular point
at which you have the
main character refer to a
particular river, right?
And I then Googled that, and
Google spell corrected it into
the actual name of
the river today.
And so then I basically from
1/3 of the book on, I was
reading the book with Wikipedia
on the side, slowly
piecing things together, and
eventually ending up feeling
like I had this euphoric moment
where I had cracked the
mystery of where this
was taking place
and what was happening.
Was that intentional?
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON:
I like that.
That's what I think should
happen in the reading process.
And I put in clues.
There's a stone arch across the
river in my local people.
It's very prominent right
next to their camp.
They live in loop meadow,
which is an oxbow
that's dried out.
And the oxbow dried out because
the river cut through
a bit of that limestone cliff
and left an arch.
Well, for early peoples, that
arch-- they call it the Stone
Bison in my book, because it
kind of looks like a bison
straddling the river.
A very extraordinary feature
that is at Vallon-Pont-D'Arc,
a famous little tourist spot
in the Ardeche in France.
And also, these words
are so ancient.
Basque is an ancient language.
Proto Indo-European is
an ancient language.
Because of the translation stuff
you can find online now,
I was able to use those things
and leave clues like that.
And I would have hated a preface
or the jacket copy or
the notorious trolls, which is
really the nicest thing I can
say about them at
Kirkus Reviews.
There's a book review service
called Kirkus, which prides
itself on its malevolence.
And I won't say anything
nastier, but the review of
"Shaman" was suggesting that
there be maps and a glossary
and a bibliography
and all this.
But this was clearly someone
passive aggressively or flat
out aggressively trying to
attack its reality as a novel.
And so luckily, I'm being
published by a wonderful
editor at a wonderful publisher,
and they're
completely on board with
doing it my way.
And I love it that you can
find out where this all
without having the outside
information.
AUDIENCE: For this book and for
the Mars books, you needed
to do a lot of research
and fill in details.
And then in one case, you're
working forward and other one
working backwards.
How was that different?
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON: They're
remarkably similar.
And the interesting thing is
that the Mars literature in
English, if gathered and put on
a bookshelf, I can tell you
for a fact-- when I was writing
the book, anyway,
which is really the late
'80s, early '90s--
is about two bookshelves'
worth of material.
Now, the literature about the
Paleolithic is somewhat
bigger, but not stupendously
bigger.
It's about four bookshelves
worth of books.
And so I also had that
library on hand.
And I would contrast this.
Antarctica, maybe just one
bookshelf worth of material
for my Antarctic novel.
And then "The Years of Rice and
Salt," where I did this
alternative history where all
the Europeans died in the
Black Death and then the world
went on for 700 years
differently with the Europeans
gone, that was 25 years of
gathering books.
And that, essentially,
was infinite.
There was no end to the amount
of books I could read to try
to figure out what world history
would have been like
without the Europeans.
And it was kind of carte blanche
when I went into a
used bookstore.
Oh, you mean the Chinese went
to Africa on these gigantic
sailing ships in the
14th century?
Great, I'll buy that.
And that, indeed, turned
out to be crucial.
Other things turned out to
be completely irrelevant.
But I had two or three bookcases
of books assembled
for "The Years of Rice and
Salt," and I essentially
crashed my system.
My brain broke.
It was like a drop in
the ocean to do
research for that one.
So the other ones have felt
much more manageable--
much more like you have a secure
topic, you can give
yourself a little graduate
degree type education very
quickly, and the more you do it,
the better you get at it,
because you have the context,
the tools, the
ability to rip a book.
And sometimes I felt like I
could touch the spine of a
book and immediately know its
entire contents by telepathy,
when I was hungry enough.
So prehistory and Mars--
the cool thing about it is that
we do have a lot of the
culture of the Paleolithic
because of those paintings,
and because of the decoration,
and because archaeology has
given us more.
Mars was more speculative,
and I had to make
up more things myself.
And no one person should have
to make up a culture.
That's why science fiction
cultures always look so thin.
It's a group effort-- a
civilizational effort to make
up a culture.
And so when one person tries to
imitate it, you have to try
to suggest that there's much
more than the things that
you're telling by a kind
of stage magic trick.
And I perfected that,
but it's hard.
And it's not as fun as having a
whole culture giving you all
of its good stuff, which I knew
that for sure when I went
to Antarctica.
I went to Antarctica, and
there's this hilarious culture
down there that I didn't have to
invent that was just giving
itself to me.
It was wonderful.
AUDIENCE: I want to go
back to the Minsky
topic and science fiction.
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON: Sure.
AUDIENCE: And the reason I'm
going to do this is because I
have a very good friend of mine,
she just published her
first novel.
She's very young.
She's for flirting already with
science, with Rosalind
Franklin and DNA.
But I feel that she may feel
like science fiction, like a
lot of people feel--
I mean, she wouldn't
be the only one--
that science fiction sort of
boxes you in and you're a
science fiction writer, and then
you have an audience like
here, where there's maybe one
woman in the audience.
And what do you have to say to
budding writers who may be
afraid of going into science
fiction because of these
reasons, and maybe expand
on that Minsky story?
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON: Well,
thank you for that question.
I think that science fiction
is the realism of our time,
and yet there are many dedicated
readers who will
never read it, because they
don't think they like or
understand science fiction.
If I had a blackboard here--
and thank God I don't--
I would say that all the genres
have the potential for
great literature and great
stories, but a timeline will
describe what's going on.
Say that you've got the
beginning of writing.
So that's, say, 3,000
BC 2,000 BC.
And a line goes right
up to the present.
So everything on that line is a
genre that can be divided up
between what we would call
mainstream, or the literature
of now, which is within,
say, 30, 40 years
of the present moment.
And then before that, it's
historical fiction, which has
a big spread, but not
an infinite spread.
It's only just the 3,000 years
of literate history, and
that's historical fiction.
Great genre.
Now, science fiction is always
about the history that we
cannot know.
So it's the future, which
we never can know.
So it's like, at that point, it
gets to be a spread, like a
weather scenario spread, where
the future can go in many
different directions.
Then alternative history, if you
postulate that something
different happened in the past
and goes off to the side, we
can never know what that would
be, and so that's another
unknown history.
And then before history began,
human beings were doing their
thing for these 30,
40,000 years.
Prehistorical literature.
But we can't really know it,
because it's not written down,
and we're working by inference
as I did here.
So science fiction is the
history that we can't now, and
that's why alternative histories
and even prehistoric
fiction are very often
filed in the
science fiction section.
That's the logical underpinning
of the genre.
And then fantasy isn't on the
timeline at all, especially
Tolkien fantasy.
It has a different history
of its own.
It's in a bubble of its own.
And as soon as you have my
schema, then you can say,
well, dang, I'm going to put a
fantasy novel right into the
historical timeline, and
Coleridge going to run into a
bunch of magicians with real
magic, and that's historical
fantasy, Tim Powers.
Then someone says, well, I'm
going to say that in the
sewers of New York right
now, there's
magicians running around.
That's urban fantasy.
A lot of that.
And so you can see
that this schema
begins to swap the genres.
But this gets to the next
part of your question.
As a young writer, or as a
reader, what do you do?
You're going to get pigeonholed
by your first success.
The marketers and the publisher
and the bookstores
are going to want to
put you somewhere.
So it's an open question where
you want to be put.
Where you're going to get the
most readers, or the most
leaders that are going to
appreciate what you're doing,
which is not the same thing.
And also kept the most
latitude to do
everything that you want.
These are complicated
questions.
It's really more than
I can go into here.
But I'm reading now the novels
about Henry VIII by Hilary
Mantel, so that's historical
fiction.
And a decade ago, I was reading
Patrick O'Brian's
novels about the Napoleonic
naval war--
the Aubrey Maturin novels,
they're called.
That's also historical
fiction.
These are beautiful novels.
What's happened is that in
modernism, domestic realism
was the only real thing.
Everything else was a despised
paraliterature.
So if you did even historical
fiction, you were doing this
second rate crap, and science
fiction, even worse.
Might as well have
been comic books.
Well, in postmodernism, there's
no condescension.
There's no position of
superiority left.
Anything can be great if you
do it, including graphic
novels, comic books, movies,
superhero novels, I mean,
anything could possibly
be great.
And in fact, we often see great
work in all the genres,
now that this bad moment of
cultural snobbery is over.
But there's a residual.
There's still residual
snobbery.
And snobbery comes out
of insecurity.
It's people thinking, I need
to feel I'm superior to
others, because secretly
I feel like
maybe I've got a problem.
Got to get over it.
The New York Times, they've
got to get over it.
The whole New York literary
establishment, they
got to get over it.
This feeling that, oh my god,
unless I'm a snob, I can't
prove that I'm good
is a terrible,
crippling, stupid response.
AUDIENCE: So you talk a little
bit about your creative
process in terms of research.
I was curious about the actual
act of sitting down and
writing in your day to day.
So if you could elaborate a
little bit about how that
works for you, how you get
your books written.
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON: Well,
I must tell you, I've been
writing, and I've been writing
full time, not counting--
well, it really means always
part time, because of being
Mr. Mom and bringing
up my kids.
But I've been writing
a lot, let's put it
that way, for 40 years.
And about 10 years ago,
I was burning out.
I was thinking, you know,
I'm tired of.
This I can't stand to sit
down and write anymore.
But what I discovered by some
experimentation that what I
was tired was sitting
indoors on my butt
in front of a screen.
And I moved my operation
outdoors into my front
courtyard under a tree so
I can see the laptop
screen in the shade.
And now, being up in Davis,
it's somewhat like here.
We're really in the northern
end or the back end of a
Mediterranean climate.
I do it every day of the year.
I write outside.
If it rains, I put a tarp
overhead, and the rain
falls around me.
It's like a bead curtain.
It's kind of great, because
I'm still writing.
If it's hot, I have a fan,
I have a mister.
The heat is by far the worst.
If it's cold, I gear up in my
snow camping gear and feel
like I'm on a little
adventure.
I've got a down hood on and
gloves, and I'm thinking, man,
I'm not just writing anymore.
I'm having a little adventure.
And it has rejuvenated me, and
I will point to "Galileo's
Dream, "2312," and "Shaman" as
the three books that have been
done entirely outdoors
using this method.
And I think I'm on
a hot streak.
And it's not coincidental.
It has to do with feeling like
it's fun again, the actual
physical act of writing.
Because as you know, everybody
who does the kind of work we
do, it's labor intensive.
It's time intensive.
You end up spending I would
reckon maybe five hours per
page, 500 pages.
I don't even want to do
the math on that.
So that's what I do.
And when I write first drafts,
I can only go a half a day.
When I'm revising, I can
go all day and more.
And the last thing is, I decided
recently that I would
write every day of the week.
I used to do it like
I call it, it
would be like carpentry.
There's nothing mystical
about it.
I'd work Monday through Friday,
take the weekend off
with my family, and get back
to it Monday morning.
A few years ago, I decided to
work on Saturdays and Sundays,
and you have 7/5 more time, and
you never lose your train
of thought.
And you can get on streaks--
sort of a Cal Ripken streak,
where it'll be a Sunday, and I
won't have written, and it's
like Sunday bedtime, and I
think, oh my god.
I can't break my streak.
So I have what I call the
Cal Ripken moment,
and I write 20 minutes.
And so I've written that day.
And sometimes it's a very
good 20 minutes of work.
And then I just put
it aside and then
I'm still on my streak.
I've had streaks of
260 days in a row.
And right through Christmas day,
right thought anything
that might possibly disturb
it, I've written though.
So that's my method now.
And it hasn't always been that
way, but it is now, and it's
making me happy.
My wife thinks I've
gone crazy.
She takes pictures of me
out in the rain and
laughs her head off.
But she can see that
I'm happier, that
I'm on a streak here.
And I thought I was near the
end of my run, but I think
I'll do a few to several more
novels, and then I'll write my
Sierra Nevada book, and that
will be my retirement project.
And I'll change again.
AUDIENCE: So you say, basically,
a lot of research
went into "Rice and Salt," and
the Middle Eastern part of
that culture kind of rather--
not exactly, but in a rather
deep way, I can confirm that
you really did a
good job there.
I cannot say much about the
Chinese or the Native American
parts, but that was
really something.
But you said that got you kind
of exhausted, and then your
new pattern of working
outdoors.
So are you saying you're not
going to take on such large
projects anymore?
Because that's probably
my favorite.
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON: Well,
thank you for that.
And I mean, that one, there is
a big Persian moment in that
one, or Iranian.
Whatever you want to say.
Once you have the Europeans out
of the picture, everybody
else has a better chance to
express their culture.
And Persia is an ancient and
powerful and beautiful
culture, so that was one
opportunity that I had.
And one of my teachers
was Iranian, living
in the United States.
That part of the novel,
that strand.
So that was a great
opportunity.
And that is a single novel.
It's just that at 900 pages
long or whatever, it was--
I'm not going to
avoid anything.
If I have an idea for another
long novel, I will curse and
gnash my teeth.
It will be a disaster.
But I won't run away from it.
But I'm sort of thinking
it won't happen.
And if it turns out to be a long
novel, the one thing I
will avoid is trilogies.
What I want to do is crush
things into one volume.
And I'm going to claim that I've
only done two trilogies.
That the one that they call the
California trilogy is more
of a triptych, or a kind of a
peculiar trio of books that
isn't a story that begins and
takes three volumes to take
place, because those are
three different novels.
So I've done it twice.
And the Washington, DC trilogy
was possibly a bad idea.
And now I'm working at about
this length, and I'm thinking
I don't see any ideas on the
horizon that should take more
than this length
to do the job.
So I'll still do the research.
I still have some kind of
horrifying problems to solve
in the novels that I
have coming next.
Formal problems.
Research problems.
But I'm going to keep them
all to one volume if I
can, that's for sure.
JON ORWANT: And I want to thank
Kim Stanley Robinson for
joining us.
KIM STANLEY ROBINSON:
Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]